in barneby being the returning officer
for the torbay constituency at the UK
parliamentary general election do hereby
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for the each candidate in the
said election is as follows foster Kevin
John Conservative Party candidate 19,000
551 Hermes Paula jackeline Green Party
1557 Murdoch Susan Joyce commonly known
as sue Maddock Labour Party candidate
4166 mcintyre anthony James commonly
known as Tony McIntyre UK Independence
Party 6540 Sanders Adrienne mark liberal
Democrat 16,000 265 the number of ballot
papers rejecters was as follows wanted
an official mark one waiting voting for
more candidates than the voter was
entitled to 51 writing all mark by which
voter could be identified to being
unmarked or holy void for uncertainty 81
a total of 135 I do hereby declare that
Kevin John Foster is duly elected as the
Member of Parliament for the torbay
constituency the turnout
well thank you madam returning officer
and ironically of all nights for me to
lose my voice but I'll try and get
through it it's a great honor to be
elected as the Member of Parliament for
our beautiful bay and I'm starting I
just think of two people who would have
loved to have been here tonight who did
so much to support me and getting to
this point the first is Jean Baker who
spent 40 years involved in torbay
politics but now is too unwell to attend
and of course the second is my mother
Linda last year wench not last year when
she realized she wouldn't make it to
this day she said she'd be here in the
shadow somewhere and I'm sure she is
it's been two years of hard work since
selection and it's been a great to
engage with the community and really put
forward a positive fresh approach that
people of tonight endorsed I'd like to
thank my fellow candidates for the fair
campaign we've heard and the way we've
been able to debate the issues in a way
that I think this has actually being
apparently credit to us all in making
comment about one of my opponents
unconscious tonight will be very
disappointing for him but I'd say it's
probably more jus with the rosette the
result tonight's more do with the party
rosette that adrian war in his lapel
than the hearty war on his sleeve was
representing this community over the
last 18 years there's a lot of work to
be done delivering the plan for the bay
as part of the long-term economic plan
the Conservative Party has put forward
for the to this country I'm delighted to
have such a strong endorsement of it
from the voters in Torquay in paignton
and I look forward to being there member
of parliament and their voice in
Westminster taking this Bay forward
thank you
you